foreign
thinking about that when we're together
I thought I had like defeated it but I
think I just kind of numbed out my
feelings to it the defeat language is is
concerning because it's a fight you're
not going to win because it's not a
fight
[Music]
oh what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
so glad that you're with us so glad that
you've joined us the greatest mental
health and married relationship podcast
ever and this is our third start I've
Got Friends walking by the window and
it's good to see my friends but it is
hard for me to do two things at once so
I'm so glad that you're with us and you
didn't even know that it happened and
I'm not supposed to tell you when I have
to restart shows over and over again and
I forgot so here we are we're here and
I'm I'm so glad that you're here don't
forget to subscribe subscribe subscribe
and pass these shows along
um I'm so grateful for you so so
grateful for you let's go to the phones
let's go to Hope in Columbus what's up
hope
hi um how are you today I'm fantastic
how about you
a little nervous but hey I'm nervous too
listen I've just train wrecked this show
starting off this morning so you can't
be any worse than I was
so what's up
um okay so I am I'm really struggling
Tennessee Okay um I think part of it is
I'm struggling with some hormonal
imbalances um since being postpartum
um and then also we have some other uh
sexual baggage that just I can't seem to
let go of tell me about it
um so
uh my husband I'm a Christian and so is
my husband and he um he was with someone
else before we were married and we've
been married three years and I just
still struggle uh thinking about that
when we're together
was that did you struggle with that
before you were married
I did yes did you struggle with that
before you had kids or is this something
new
um it's kind of off and on I it was a
really big struggle the first year or
two of our marriage and I kind of
I thought I had like defeated it but I
think I just kind of numbed out my
feelings to it
why do you think this is something you
need to go to war with
or let me ask it in a different way
uh the defeat language is is concerning
because it's a fight you're not gonna
win because it's not a fight
um
what is it about you
that you feel like isn't enough
because it feels like it's about your
husband's past and this and that and
he's been with other people and all that
this is about you feeling like you're
not enough
tell me about that yeah I'm not sure I'm
not sure to answer that
am I off am I wrong
no I wouldn't say you're wrong
that's been with you for a long time huh
yeah I think so
do you know where that comes from
I think it's from my mom
tell me about that
um she
I just think she would say to me as a
kid like one particular that just is
stuck in my mind is
um she she asked me she's like don't you
just wish that don't you wish you had
these like feminine features and you
were more beautiful and you just
you're dude you're very good at
um
christianese
at sugarcoating things be very direct
what'd your mom tell you
she told me I wasn't pretty pretty much
it would be really cool if your body
looked different
yeah yeah
and so every time you stand before your
husband you think I can't be as
attractive as
the other girl was five or six or seven
years ago
and he must be yeah
he must be worried he's he's picturing
her thinking of her instead is he
no no no no because he has a naked woman
right in front of him right
uh I'm sorry your mom told you that
she shouldn't have told you that
that was her projecting her own
insecurities onto you
and you were her little girl and you
didn't deserve that
and for all of us parents out there this
is what this looks like 5 or 10 or 15 or
20 years later when we put our
insecurities on our kids
then they stand before
the person they love
and they say this is all of me
and that person says I'm all in and we
go no you're not
because even even our parents weren't
all in right
um
yeah have you told your husband about
this
does he know um I tried I tried to talk
to him about the like how I'm struggling
like with intimacy a couple months ago
but I don't think he knew how big of a
deal it is because I like I still try to
be with him but for me it's just not
like
I don't feel as connected to him as I
should I feel like I should be able to
okay
um I want to back out of the whole
conversation there's a weird thing that
happens with our brains and our brains
are story making machines
and so here's a good example uh it's
like a simple example I can have a
morning where I have my morning coffee
at my house which is just part of my
routine and then this morning I'll use
this morning it's a great example
um I have my morning coffee at my house
which is a lot
um and then I went to breakfast I go to
breakfast every morning once a week in
the mornings with my son and I had a
whole bunch more coffee there and then I
get here and somebody had brought me
like hey we know you like this
sugar-free vanilla fluffy thing we got I
got you on so suddenly I have had 18
cups of coffee in the single morning and
my body is jittered out and my brain
thinks
I've got anxiety issues
my brain begins looking for stories that
back up why my body is is rattling the
way it is
and it must be because of this and oh
yeah because of this and I happen to
walk by
um you know I work in at Ramsey
Solutions I work at a big Media company
and there's there's walls of banks of
different news shows on and
um oh it's because like then my heart
starts beating a little bit faster so
it's my body it's my mind
in search of a story that backs up how I
what my body's doing does that make
sense
and so I can imagine a scenario where
you still struggle with feeling secure
in your body I get that totally totally
and I can also Imagine you've just had
is this your first kid
yeah yeah just had your first baby so
your husband is married to a completely
different woman right now and you're
married to a completely different man
right now and you'll probably haven't
had that conversation yet and sex used
to be look like X and Y and Z and now
everybody's tired everybody's buzzing
around everybody
misjudged how many diapers have to be
changed in a certain day
nobody feels sexy when they're getting
peed on and there's poop under their
nails and when we have to take the trash
like Everything's changed
and then you start feeling like we're
having sex and it doesn't feel as good
as it did or feels different or he's
being a little bit weird or a little bit
different
and now the story machine cranks up to
try to backfill why our bodies feel how
our bodies feel do you see what I'm
saying
yeah and then it starts to magnify
itself and so what I want to do is be
really open and vulnerable and vocal
about what's actually happening not the
stories that we're creating about what's
happening
here's what that means hey honey sex
feels different now
and by the way it won't forever but it
does right now
does it feel different for you I feel
your body is different right now
or I feel you're not as engaged in it or
I'm having trouble staying engaged in it
and this can lead to an adventure of
I'll figure out a way to help you be
engaged you tell me you see I'm saying
now it can be a whole adventure of y'all
discovering each other further or it can
be the thing that shuts everything down
you see what I'm saying yeah when sex is
wrapped up in shame
and when you have self-doubt when he's
got self-doubt when he doesn't know what
to say or how to say it you don't know
what how to tell them what you need and
what you like when we get into this back
and forth shame-filled world
the awkwardness can lead us to you know
what I'm I'm good I I don't want to
enter into that awkward space so I'm
just going to stay by myself and now the
story machine just loses its mind okay
here's the here's your new assignment
are you ready
mm-hmm
all right let me just pause there tell
me what you're feeling or thinking as
I'm talking you can and you can say dude
you're full of crap or
um tell me what you're thinking
um I'm still just not sure like how to
tell so how to express that to my
husband because
I don't I don't want to like destroy his
confidence because he's you know he he's
lost a lot of weight recently like 70
pounds and he's the most attractive he's
ever been to me and then as soon as it
gets like to the time for intimacy it
just like
I I struggle with that
are
can I say something mean
yeah no it's not mean it's just direct
is that cool
yeah he knows you're not enjoying
yourself
I know you
yes
that's the secrets are destroying your
relationship far more than being honest
would
and that's what I say I don't think this
has to do with his appearance I don't
think this has to do with his past
I think this has to do with you not
feeling like you're worthy of a guy that
looks as good as he does right now
I think you're
you're bringing a story to the table
that you're not enough you're he he just
he accepted you but man he wish he could
have so and so and so and so and so and
so and then your mind goes Off to the
Races
at some point you have to decide
I am not going to engage in those
thoughts when that thought lightning
bolts in your mind you're gonna
literally say out loud nope not doing
that
and you're going to have some other
thoughts to backfill it some really
romantic intimate times y'all were
together or times y'all laughed really
hard until you almost threw up together
I don't think it's I don't think it's
worth your energy to try to mine to go
down a rabbit hole every time you're in
the middle of having sex and be like
okay why I'm not really
into this like I think why that's the
worst the worst time to be thinking
through those kind of things right
because then you're not present in that
moment
um I want you to pick up a book called
Come As You Are by Emily nagotsky and
we'll link to it in the show notes Here
um it's the greatest
um book on female sexuality I've ever
read it's not a faith-based book by any
means okay
um but she is a teacher and the book is
easy to read and I have had very very
few people very few people not come back
and say that book changed my life it's
incredible and he might want to read it
too here's the Crux of it and the reason
I love it she takes away the idea of sex
drive she changes the picture of what
attraction is and she creates a
compelling case for sexuality especially
in like a marriage relationship being in
very much Environmental
there's a it's not a sex drive like he's
got more of it I've got less of it
sometimes I it's a series of offs and
ons
okay and the goal for each couple is to
figure out how can we turn on as many
ons in this environment and turn off as
many offs
especially after you just had a baby
because everything is different now
does that make sense
yeah yeah so here's an example in my
house I've told us on the show before I
thought that
um like in my house
for years the kitchen had to be clean
before we we went back and and to the in
the in the back room and I thought for
years
my wife was putting our time together
second to a clean to having the dishes
out of the sink
and I started taking it personal
like seriously like I'm less like look
at this I'm a smoke show all right I I
I've got to be more attractive than a
than like seven dishes in the sink
and in her mind she had a picture of the
way a house is supposed to look so that
she had accomplished her job
and she had created a story that
if this isn't done then I'm not doing my
job and if I haven't done my job I can't
relax and enjoy myself
and so what we were doing is we had two
stories going about the dishes that
neither of them were truthful or
accurate but there were stories we were
bringing to the table ended up being a
mess and so finally when we sat down
because we had to
we neglected these conversations our
whole marriage we had to start having
these hard conversations or our marriage
wasn't going to make it
we started talking about the series of
offs and ons
and then it was like I can't move
forward because of the way I feel about
me if I haven't uh if there's dishes in
the sink
and for me it was like oh this has
nothing to do with me this has to do
with the fact that this is a story she
tells about herself I'm gonna get all
the dishes out of the sink all the time
see what I'm saying and now I'm about
something completely different
um oh you need me to text you in the
morning you want me to tell you this
thing you want me to remind you of dude
I can do that that's simple that's
taking another off off the table and
turning another switch on and so it
became a fun fun filled Adventure
figuring out what are all the odds and
what are all the offs and ons and offs
like are not all very few of them are
sexual most of them are creating an
environment it's why you can go to a
hotel
and just
call cause the wallpaper to peel itself
off right because you're like getting
after it and then you come back home and
you're in a different environment and
everything's like whoosh it's all gone
right and so it's you mining
your environment you deciding I'm not
going to have these thoughts about his
old girlfriends or his old what ex-wife
or whatever I'm not gonna I'm not going
there in my head that's a choice and
over time your brain will quit
defaulting to that that is your brain
trying to come up with a story
that is going to justify you not being
enough for him and by the way hope he
chose you you're enough
do you believe that
kinda okay
today is going to be the first day you
tell the full truth okay
you're not going to destroy him you're
gonna tell him you love him you can tell
him he looks really good and you're
gonna tell him three months after having
a baby I'm struggling with sex and I'm
struggling with how it feels and when it
doesn't feel like I thought it was going
to or the whole environment isn't like
what I thought then I start cranking up
stories like you're thinking about your
ex like that I'm not enough that my mom
told me my body doesn't look good and
you probably think like she does put all
those things out there
do you trust him enough to hold those
things with you
oh yeah okay
and maybe you write yourself a letter
write him a letter and read it to him so
that you don't um get nervous or don't
get jittery or don't miss those things
um and then you guys get to do the
funnest thing in the entire world
as you get to practice
you get to practice what intimacy is
going to look like in this new season
with a new baby you're going to practice
what intimacy looks like where you start
feeling confident in your own body and
confident in the fact that he picked you
he picked you as the one person he's
going to be intimate with for the rest
of his life he chose you
and you all get to figure out together
what offs and awns in your home mean
dude
there's a lot of things to practice you
can practice free throws you can
practice you know I don't know cutting
boards in your backyard with your new
circular saw there's few things on earth
better
than practicing
how we're going to be more intimate
together and how we're both gonna love
sex more over time
then I get much better than that
but that starts with vulnerability and
starts with you being honest and that oh
starts today we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Thomas
in Milwaukee what's up Thomas
uh hi
hi
um I'm a chronic procrastinator and
most of the time I procrastinate things
that are inconsequential so I didn't
think that it was you know heavy enough
to be a good fit for the show but then I
recently unknowingly ended up
procrastinating something that turned
out to be devastatingly consequential
so I just have these two issues now that
I'm facing that I was hoping I could get
your help with
if you uh I think my face is actually on
the Wikipedia page for procrastination
so it's good to meet you Thomas I too am
a procrastinator
um I turned in my chapter two of my new
book at 12 22 A.M
the day it was due the other night so
I'm with you man
um and by the way there is no too small
to call the show man
um because it may be inconsequential
like you may be like procrastinating and
it's and it's inconsequential like it's
not costing you your home or your job or
your relationship
but it beats you up man and you feel
ashamed of it it's annoying and you're
always wondering about it because I've
been there too what'd you do would you
what what big thing did you blow out of
the water
um
the reason why it's bothering me is
because there was a
that it could have been easily avoided
and I didn't realize it until
it was too late you're speaking in
circles man tell me tell me tell me tell
me
I went to the I
felt like I didn't need it for the
longest time
finally when I was like I should
probably get into glasses I still put it
off I put it off and I put it off and
slowly but surely my my left eye is my
bad eye and it's starting to get from
where you know it's so day by day it's
so gradual that like you don't notice it
until all of a sudden you're like whoa I
can't see something that I very
obviously should be able to see so I
finally finally finally set up the
appointment and
everything was seemed to be going fine
for the longest time they're just like
do you have any pitching ready uh
redness you know excessive discharge any
of that and I was like no no no
everything seemed fine
um they covered my left eye right eye
seemed fine they isolated my left eye
and
um they held their hand out to the side
and they said how many fingers am I
holding up and there was a void where
their hand should have been and that was
the first time that I realized I was
like okay that ain't good and then they
had me read letters and I could see the
letter that I was looking at but the
letter on either side was blurry and
okay I was like okay well that was
different from the other eye that's also
not good and they checked my eye
pressure and they say anything above 20
is considered is considered high and
then anything over 30 is considered like
dangerously high and they said mine was
40. it's always way I was like way way
above to where
um
to wear basically basically I was I was
diagnosed with glaucoma
38 yeah and
and it was just hard because
I
I had so much time to do it
and I know that
kicking yourself isn't like useful but
then at the same time it's like well
yeah it's it just sucks that because
like I hold on is it directly because
you took a while to get your glasses
uh yeah I went the last time I had your
glasses which was 2007. I know but I've
I've not heard and again I'm not an
expert on on this at all
um
but I I don't know that glaucoma is
attached directly to a mixed mismatched
eye prescription is it uh it's it's
pressure in the eye
and they they check for that when you go
in for your eye appointments okay so and
basically if they would if I would have
gone in for a checkup to get new glasses
they would have checked my high pressure
they could have caught it sooner and
prevented uh and prevented the the
damage from occurring over a long period
of time gotcha so now it sucks because
because I'm gonna live for like 80 more
years and so now that's like a long time
to sit here with this bum janky eye that
doesn't work right and so now it's like
I can't like you know I can't like get
away from it like I'm I'm reminded of it
every waking moment I can see it all the
time so it's like you know I don't even
have like the the luxury of repressing
it you know because every time my eyes
are open I'm like reminded of it and I
have to put drop some eyes now three
times a day so that reminds me of it
also
so I'm just like how do I come to terms
with with that like this is going to be
like my life from now on because I've
been an adult for 20 years now so I'm
sitting here going like boy I have a
couple more of those 20-year lifespans
so it's like when I'm 58 I'm still gonna
be I'm still gonna be dealing with it
when I'm 78 you know you know so it's
just like it's occurring to me like how
long my life is gonna be still dealing
with this thing that there's gonna be as
far as I know no cure for like anytime
soon
you know they're they're only dealing
with you know treatment and prevention
but if you already have it then it just
sucks to be you I guess
um so yeah so I'm just you know like I'm
just having a hard time just coming to
terms with
with like this is my like reality from
now on yeah that that's that's a
different conversation than
procrastination
that we'll get to that but this is this
is more about you just coming to terms
with
um
a medical condition that's become a new
reality for you and what you can't see
on the other side of it yet is
um a neural adaptations
your brain figures things out not saying
that your eye is going to magically be
able to see
what I'm going to tell you is in five
years and 10 years you're in two years
and three years your body's ability to
Norm your new situation is extraordinary
it's just magic
um I wish it's not magic but it feels
Magic
and so right now on this side of it the
grief is so Raw it's so devastating your
anger at your body your anger at
yourself all that stuff is so raw right
now that every time you open your eye
it's just this pulsing rage
my promise to you is that begins to
dissipate over time and as you live into
this new reality just the way it is and
there's going to come a moment when you
forget about it
okay not forget about like you can't see
but there's going to be a moment when
you're grabbing for something and you're
you just turn a little bit more so that
your other eye can help compensate for
it
I've got friends who are War veterans
that have different challenges and they
just go about their day and if you ask
them about it like oh yeah yeah that's
the thing but it just becomes part of
their day and so I'm telling you that to
tell you right now
dealing with the guilt you feel over not
taking care of your taking care of this
the like you're imagining a bunch of
different variables into this situation
okay let's let it be what it is it is
and it's gonna it's gonna be it's gonna
suck for a while
you're gonna be upset for a while and
dude all that's okay man
the how am I gonna live moving forward
you're gonna take care of your eyes
moving forward and you know that I know
that this won't ever happen again we
both know that and so let's make peace
with that and let's exhale on that is
that fair
oh yes
going to war against yourself and your
body is not going to help is what I'm
saying being devastated and sad
completely normal and if you skip over
that spot that's going to Loop you back
into more war with yourself and with
other people
I would just be sad for a season stinks
man
stinks but the pain you feel right now
is not going to be the pain you feel
when you're 58. okay
okay
and and it sounds trite but you just
gotta trust me on that okay question now
is is asking yourself what does like you
said you procrastinate about a lot of
stuff little stuff now in your world Big
Stuff
um tell me about that
um
well mostly it's
things that either just take a few
minutes or like for example I have
posters that I purchased like two years
ago that I just haven't put up on the
wall because I don't have like you know
I'm an introvert so I don't have like
people over so I could just not put it
up and no one would care
or you know my car clicker is dead but
then I'm not like I don't so I haven't
locked my car in several months or
basically like
basically anytime I hit anytime I don't
know how to do something I kind of hit a
roadblock and I can't push past it uh
I've been wanting to learn how to sell
books on Amazon and I spent 200 on some
video editing software that I haven't
learned how to use yet because I can
still use the old one that isn't as good
but I know how to use it uh you know I I
have I have huge backlogs
that are like overwhelming I have a
video game backlog and a steam backlog
which are ridiculous I have about 100
songs that I want to learn the lyrics to
but it's like thrash metal so you can't
hear the lyrics just by uh by listening
to it you actually have to sit down with
the lyrics and learn learn it one by one
you know and I have a movie backlog and
okay so I have let me let me jump in
here
you've got a bunch of cool stuff that
you want to do
because I also I also go to yoga which
then ends up taking almost two hours a
day out of that time and then by the
time I come home from work I just have
this little little tiny piece of time
before I have to leave and then when I
come back I just had like a few precious
hours before I have to like before I
have to like go to bed and after work
I'm tired hold on
dude somebody early on in your life
told you that you suck and you're kind
of a loser who was that
uh I don't think anyone I was I was
raised in a military family but I was a
good kid you know my parents were strict
but fair I wasn't in trouble at all uh
my parents kind of took the hands-off
approach to raising me because I I
checked all the boxes you know I got
myself up to for school I did my
homework I didn't talk back I you know
comply Hey listen compliance can often
be a trauma response my friend
happened that kind of changed me into
that gear or whatever I it must have
been before I remember were you bullied
in school
uh there was there was a few instances
of it in fourth and fifth grade but it
wasn't like a chronic it wasn't like a
chronic thing it was just like a couple
of times for like a few moments where I
was I was kind of picked out of the
crowd and do you have you know do you
have anything do you have any mental
health Diagnostics
um not not that I you know not that I'm
aware of I'm generally not an anxious
guy like my life is like in order like
you know I enjoy having my freedom and
having all the Time in the World to do
whatever I want all day every day you
know except go to work so
um so I don't have I'm not afflicted by
many of the things that a lot of the
other you know callers have uh you know
I did have anxiety about just call but I
think I'm not an anxious person
generally
um just when I get done with work I'm
just kind of like blah you know I'm
diligent at my job and I I you know I do
more you know I do way more working than
talking you know so just when I'm done
I'm just like tired and I have to suck
it up and go to yoga and then when I'm
done with that and I'm like super mega
extra tired so I just kind of go into
like blob mode and a lot of the stuff it
doesn't even feel like I'm
procrastinating at the time like I can
rationalize why it's a good idea to do
this instead of this other thing and
then next thing you know it's been three
weeks and I'm like oh yeah I didn't do
that thing three weeks ago that I had
already put off for six weeks you know
so so let me let me challenge you here
you might think that you have to get
through this movie backlog and learning
the lyrics to songs and learning new
songs on guitar and learning how to make
films
it sounds like you know what you love
doing
collecting cool ideas
yeah I do sort of like just just like
making large I like I I don't know if I
did it on purpose or not but I just had
like all these huge lists of things to
do and then it's it's almost like
overwhelming but you know it's like but
hold on hold on
procrastination I don't think you're
procrastinating
I don't like I think you like making
cool lists it'd be cool to know how to
do this and maybe your thing is making
lists
what I want you to do is to stop beating
up Thomas
because I think Thomas is a good guy
and you've created a a hell of your own
making of these shoulds and have to's
that don't exist
there are a few things you're gonna not
lock your car for long enough and
someone's gonna come steal and it's
going to be just like your eye that's
the that's a pattern right
yeah so there is some wisdom in saying
okay what do I really need to do
and then what do I want to do
and then let's look at all those lists
and maybe maybe pick one
here's the thing
you don't like uh you don't really want
to self-publish a book right now you
might someday but you don't right now
and so cool you're into yoga right now
it's okay to just be into yoga right now
I got friends that are obsessed with Jiu
Jitsu and they don't do anything else
they don't even talk to the kids that
much they just do Jiu-Jitsu great
does that make you see what I'm saying
like you've built it's not the things
it's the pressure you've put on yourself
and you do that pressure then crowds out
the things that you do need to get done
like you do need to go get your eyes
checked you need to go to the doctor
make sure you're healthy
sounds like you've
um
almost list making becomes compulsive
and you just then it's almost like
hoarding except you're hoarding to-do
lists
and you crowd out your mind you like
kind of like a hoarder fills up their
house so they can't even get in and out
of the house they can't make a way to
the bathroom
that's what you've done in your mind
with all this stuff It's gotta get done
I gotta Build It Up gotta and dude then
you lose the enjoyment just watching a
movie or just jamming on some new thrash
metal
see what I'm saying
yes it just so should I just get rid of
all my lists of all my lists
because I'll still I'll still know in
the back of my mind that they're there
but then no no no I think I think you
change your relationship with your list
foreign
the stuff isn't the issue here the stuff
isn't the issue it's your relationship
to the stuff
that's the problem
you
you've created a world where you don't
believe you're enough
and you don't believe going to work and
working really hard and being good at
your job and then going to yoga because
it's something you enjoy that gets you
moving your body and helps to sleep you
don't feel like that's enough
and you're chasing what else your quote
unquote supposed to be or should be
doing
and you fill it with things like watch
movies you fill it with things like play
video games you fill it with things like
learn lyrics to thrash metal songs
and those in and of themselves for most
of us Aren't Enough
for purpose they're fun
they give us joy like a hobby but it
doesn't feel the purpose
Gap and you are spinning your wheels man
because you don't think you're enough
and you are dude
and if you if you believe you're enough
then
if you don't get to the movies that's
fine because I'm good
I really want to take guitar lessons
Thomas I do have been playing for like
30 years now 35 I've been playing
forever
and I should be I played at a big event
the other day every guitarist and every
band was better than me it was annoying
and I've been playing too long and I was
like dude I gotta take lessons I'm
taking less forget I'm taking lessons
Thomas I have not signed up for a lesson
yet you know what that means I'm pretty
good at guitar and I'm good enough for
what I'm gonna do for the rest of my
life for right now maybe one day I'll
take lessons and get good just not right
now and I'm not going to beat myself up
over it
do you see the difference in that
relationship
oh yeah well I think I think part of it
is that because I have so much time
that I think that I like putting it on a
list it's like well I could just get I
just have the rest of my life to get to
it so it doesn't matter if I get to it
now or a year from now or two years from
now
but then it all just it kind of
accumulates and then next thing you know
it's like when you watch Netflix and you
can't decide what to watch and you just
spend a half hour trying to decide and
then you just turn it off yes yes and
yes and so there's one way out of this
lists don't work for you
and so let's take a season off from
making lists let's try that
I would be willing to bet that your list
making is an anxiety response it's a way
that you and your mind are trying to
control your day
control your life a life that you feel
doesn't have purpose and meaning because
you're just Thomas
so let's stop making lists for a season
and let's be highly intentional about
making sure we know there's four or five
things we got to get done
put them in a calendar put them on your
phone but uh put on I mean put them on
your calendar that's on your phone
and get your stuff done
because it sounds like when you got a
task to do you'll go get the task done
you'll get your job done you'll not
you're going to show up for for a Sunday
dinner with your family you're going to
do those things
um
so let's put those things on the
calendar and let's take a break from
making lists lists for a while
and let's give yourself some space start
asking yourself not what are the things
I have to do what are the things I want
to do
what are the things that bring me joy
what are the things that bring me
purpose
there's gonna be a few things brother
you're gonna have to just suck up and do
you got to go to the doctor you got to
get your car thing fixed so nobody
steals your stuff out of your car
you got to do those things but if you
bought posters two years ago and you
haven't put them up you don't want those
posters sell them sell them today you
don't want them because if you want them
you'd put them up just get rid of them
and give yourself that peace if you're
not gonna watch those hundred movies
just get rid of that list it's not gonna
happen and yes it's going to be back in
the back of your head it will go away
because you'll fill it up with more
stuff
but let's look at those lists as though
they are stuff in the house of a hoarder
and let's begin to ask yourself what do
I I'm not gonna I'm not gonna learn the
songs to the lyrics to 30 thrash metal
songs not gonna do it so I'm done with
that one let's move on to the next
and let's start giving Thomas a lot of
Grace and a lot of peace and let's stop
asking ourselves beating ourselves of
what I gotta do what I gotta do what I
gotta do
and ask ourselves what do I get to do
today what I want to do today
what I want to be a part of long term
let's start there man be nice to Thomas
I like that guy we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com
deloni and get the home buyer Edge today
this is a paid advertisement and MLS ID
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org Equal
Housing lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to Rachel
in Manchester
New Hampshire what's up Rachel
hi Dr John how are you so good how are
you
I'm doing well thank you a little
nervous but uh grateful to be on the
show awesome thanks for joining us
what's up
um so my question is excuse me um how do
I raise my children to live in this
technology focused Society without
allowing them to become upset
hmm
I don't know you told me you tell me I'm
trying to figure that out myself I don't
know what to do
um tell me about your kids and tell me
what you're struggling with
um so my husband and I are expecting our
first child in December so we don't have
any children right now
um but we've been you know listening to
you and Dave Ramsey and we've been
talking about what we want our uh family
values to be and a big one is you know
not being so obsessed with their phones
that they will inevitably have
eventually and to value
human to human contact and interaction
this one this one's actually easy Rachel
easy
okay you called the right guy
um because I'm an addict when it comes
to my phone and so it's something I've
had to just deal with like I would if I
was addicted to alcohol
um
your kids your first kid your second kid
your third kid are going to find out the
way the world works by watching you and
your husband
okay and so if you want to create a
world where phones are not the
centerpiece of that world at least until
they get into grade school
make phones like a screwdriver it just
stays in the drawer it's a tool that we
use when we need it ta-da
and your kids will not even understand
that's part of the world now here's a
couple of caveats to that
um when my son was born my wife and I
were Maniacs because it was right when
iPads were coming out everywhere and
cell phones were just ever I mean there
and I it just felt wrong I I just
something about it wasn't right probably
in retrospect it was just because I was
afraid of change
um and I was using these Cavalier we're
all going to die probably very similar
to the guy that was in charge of a horse
farm and then all of a sudden Henry Ford
started driving model T's everywhere and
he's like you know what's gonna happen
right so there we go
but my son one time he was two
um and he was late to speak he was very
late to to be fluent but I remember we
sat down in a restaurant and he looked
at we had a laminated uh menu and he
they sat it down and he started dropping
his fingers trying to expand the menu
as though it was like you know like a
cell phone trying to make the picture
bigger
and both me and my wife looked at each
other he did not he had never seen us do
that that was not from our house he'd
pick that up somewhere just in passing
whether that was at the supermarket or
somewhere at a family gathering so
they're gonna pick it up they're gonna
see it
but they're going to learn how to live
with your values by watching how you and
your husband live your values
and then when they get to elementary
school my son was in fifth grade and I
think he was the only one maybe one
other kid didn't have already have a
smartphone and all that stuff so it will
happen early
and it's just gonna be like everything
else whether it's I have to have the
right 10 issues or I got to have the
right Gadget or I gotta have the right
um why I don't have the right you know
bat bag for the baseball team you're
gonna be fighting that that's just human
nature kids want to fit in and they want
to be like their friends and they want
to be cool and that's not weird that's
normal that's Developmental and
sometimes we can't afford certain things
and so we're going to teach them about
realities of money and sometimes I'm not
going to buy you a 400 or 100 pair of
jeans because you grow seven inches
every week and so like right some of
those natural conversations phones are
just going to be a part of that
conversation too
right yes all your friends has it and
have them and I my job is to keep your
mind safe and they're not good for you
and so we're not gonna do that in my
house ta-da and my son I've talked about
on the show but he called me on it once
and he was right
um as he was entering middle school
because he's not he's the only kid you
know that doesn't have some access to
some kind of phone and he said dad you
took away the phone fine you say that
these things aren't good for me and my
you know fine but I got nothing
and when my friends come over no video
game like we've got nothing and he was
right and so I went I I went and we
moved some budget stuff around and I
bought a foosball table and I bought
like an air hockey table off Amazon had
it shipped to the house and I got him a
bow and arrow like I got him some things
to do that he could go do with his
friends that he could do by himself that
didn't involve so he called me on the
carpet and he was right I had to provide
some alternative activities for him that
were different
um and now we've got a cool thing to do
we go out in the front yard and shoot
our arrows and we man you talk about
some trash talking in the deloney house
when we're playing air hockey together
right you see what I'm saying so I even
had to adapt and learn and get some new
things and learn some new things and we
were in a financial position to do that
but we got the cheapest ones we could
because we're going to destroy them
because that's the house that we have
um is that helping
yeah no absolutely yeah we've heard you
um as I said both of us listen to your
show so we've heard you talk about how
you
don't prioritize cell phones and devices
at home and you have other means of you
know giving your kids things to do when
these days everyone just shoves them in
front of a TV screen here's one of my
operating rules whenever a child walks
into a room I put whatever screen I'm
looking at down
even if I tell them hey I'm in the
middle of sending a text message I need
you to wait a minute that's okay hey I'm
in the middle of working on a work email
right now I need you to give me two
minutes okay
um most of the time I'm just mindlessly
scrolling like an idiot and it's good
that I put the phone down but that's one
of our rules I want my kids to know you
are more important than whatever flashy
thing is in front of me
that makes complete sense and
I will challenge any parent I can be
wrong here I don't think I am
your kids cannot compete with the the
psychologist and neurobiologist and tech
companies who have all joined forces to
create the single most addictive device
that's ever existed
they can't compete and so to hand that
to a sixth grader or to a ninth grader
and say well you only get 30 minutes
is like handing cocaine to a kid and
saying you only get to do a little bit
right it's not it's just it's just not
fair it's not it's not it's not
um Integris because it's impossible
you're lighting up a kid's brain like a
Christmas tree and then you're going to
hold them accountable when you can't pay
attention when he gets fidgety when she
just wants to grab the phone grab the
phone and grab the phone
that's not I mean you can't do that man
you can't give a kid cocaine and get mad
at them because they're running around
the house you can't do that right so I
I've I may be proven wrong and I may be
like you know what son I screwed this up
but my Approach is as little as as
humanly possible
because they're already getting it
everywhere and by the way my son now
he's in middle school and you know every
school's got computers and all that dude
he can fly around a computer now
it took him like one second and so this
idea that they're going to be behind
they're not going to be digitally native
not dude they're so intuitive and we as
a society have no idea I keep pretty
close tabs on the AI world
what's coming
holy smokes dude we're about to be
living in a Sci-Fi movie in a profound
way and so I'm not worried at all about
the intuitive nature of Technology
integration
it's common sister it's coming and so
screens will be I think lower on on the
on the priority list in the coming years
okay okay I think this stuff is going to
be so integrated and braided into our
lives that um
keeping them from a phone will be the
least of our challenges and that's okay
I I welcome what AI can can bring to us
and what what advances it will help us
as a
Society
um and it could get off the rails and
Terminator 2 could actually happen right
um but Rachel remember these things
these two important things they're
watching everything you do
they're watching everything you do and
a kid walks in the room the screens go
down I think starting there is a great
place and congratulations to you and
your husband for thinking through what
kind of parents do we want to be what
what's our picture of what our home is
going to look like and let's reverse
engineer that early on so that that
picture comes true good for you Rachel
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back and hey the song
of the day
is
Queen and David Bowie's under pressure
quick left turn here the other day I was
getting off I mean getting onto the
airplane
in the front row of my Southwest flight
was
that's right Vanilla Ice it's incredible
and I man I wanted to say what's up and
I didn't I don't want to be that guy
um I always appreciate people say hi to
me and I'm not near as famous as Vanilla
Ice
I just felt like man back in middle
school he was the soundtrack to most of
my failed romances and I thought we had
a moment did you uh want to ask him if
he actually stole the baseline from the
song I didn't
I'm I I cannot tell you how much
restraint it took me to walk by him and
go word Dear Mother I almost did that
dude I can't tell you it was coming out
and I was like stop stop stop stop just
keep walking man
um because people come up to me and they
they tell me things that I say on the
show that I don't remember saying it and
I just think it's weird
um they'll walk like there's nothing
stranger than sitting eating Chick-fil-A
in an airport and someone walks by and
goes is that rocket diarrhea bro and I'm
like what oh cause I say that a lot
right so anyway that's a long left turn
that's some deep Cuts if you're a
Vanilla Ice fan which let's be honest we
all are you'll know that the Baseline of
his famous Ice Ice Baby may or may not
have been completely ripped off and
lifted
from Queen and David Bowie's classic hit
under pressure
what a tune man what a tune you wanna
have some Spotify fun today
procrastinating for whatever it is you
should be doing that's going to advance
your real life go down a YouTube rabbit
hole about under pressure and Ice Ice
Baby but until we get there
the song of the days Queen and David
Bowie's under pressure and it goes like
this
um
bidet
baby
[Music]
pressure
pressing down on me pressing down on you
no man asked for under pressure that
burns a building down splits a family in
two puts people on the streets
um
that's okay
that's okay
that's right folks this is the greatest
podcast ever we'll see you soon
[Music]